honored walk is lon chaney long jean
watches have 110 World's Fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other time
fees lon Jean the world's most honored
watch is made and guaranteed by the lawn
Jean with no watch company it's time for
the launching horoscope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour tour show you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a presentation of
the lawn gene which nor wats company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lon Jean
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the lawn gene Cronus coat mr.
Henry Hazlitt editor of The Freeman and
contributing editor of Newsweek magazine
and mr. william bradford huie editor of
the american mercury our distinguished
guest for this evening is mr. oscar are
youing Federal Security Administrator
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker's mr. Ewing our
conosco audience knows you sir is one of
the more controversial figures in
Washington they know that your
opponent's charge that you are an
advocate of state medicine at a night we
would particularly like the question you
on your plan to include the
hospitalization benefits in the old age
security program now will you stay for a
sir an explanation for that plan as
briefly as possible well must hear the
plan proposes to include
among the benefits that go to the people
who are entitled to old age and
survivors benefit benefits and as those
from whom wage deductions have been
taken paid into the fund that there be a
hospitalization insurance it would cover
by 1953 about seven million people there
would be about five and a half million
people over 55 over 65 about a million
one hundred thousand dependent children
and roughly 400,000 widows and people
who are taking care of those children
the whole idea is that we can give that
hospitalization insurance up to 60 days
without having to take out any
additional wage deductions our present
financing will meet that the program
would work very simply for man one of
these people entitled to it became sick
and he's doctor decided he needed
hospitalization the doctor would arrange
it we don't guarantee he gets into a
hospital but if it is arranged we do
take care of the expense it would help
mr. Ewing what would that cost about the
programmer you figure well our estimates
mr. highs were there about two hundred
million dollars a year it may be a
little more a little less well you say
you don't have to increase present taxes
together no because this cost would be
about if we were having a special wage
deduction for it it would be less than
two-tenths of one percent one-tenth by
the employer in one-tenth by the
employee well our present financing can
take care of the present the present
rate is a one and a half or on the
employer and one and a half on the
employee at 12 3 and you don't think it
would pay to postpone the increase in
the rates instead of putting in a new
program using the money for
program no I do not because i think the
these are so small this this program
relatively speaking the cost is so small
that it can be taken care of without any
interference with the overall plan
that's already been made to simplify mr.
Ewing our audience understands that
there is an argument now over whether we
shall extend federal security federal
government security or whether we should
attempt to limit it now you are the one
of the ones who believes that we should
extend the Federal Security program well
I tell you mr. Joey I'm a firm believer
in social insurance that is where people
through wage deductions or other means
pay into an insurance program and get
the benefits back I am NOT one for one
minute to advocate payments out of these
things out of general taxes well let's
our our people understand that or have
heard a great deal about the British
system and about socialization of
medicine in Britain now is it your view
sir that you approve that system that
British system and that you would like
to see ultimately such a system in the
United States all that but there are
many differences between our proposal
for national health insurance and what
the British proposed for ended the big
difference mr. Hillary is that the
British pay eight nights of the cost out
of general taxes and we wouldn't pay a
penny on it no you're not in favor of
paying for any of these services out of
general taxes no sir well mr. Ewing eyes
I recall in 1948 when you put forward
your larger program you and yourself
estimated that that program would cost
something like four to six billion
dollars a year that's right and that
1960 would be up to ten billion dollars
a year now I have you oh I don't recall
well anyway but it was four to six
billion around that neighborhood now
have you retreated from that program or
is this step one in a new program or
what is it how do you conceive no I have
never traded one
Incheon that I had my own advocacy of it
my own belief that it's a desirable
thing to do however what I'm proposing
here is not substitute Nora's at a
retreat from that at all it's simply
that here is a particular group that
people over 65 years of age who have
more sickness than the average who have
less money with which to pay for it and
who have less money with which to buy
voluntary insurance and I'm I would urge
this program in order to take care of
them now you already have the money i
mean the government is collecting the
money to cover it yes you're collecting
more money than you are now spending
under the federal social security
program is that correct sir yes it'd be
quite accurate we it's always been
expected in the early years that we
would collect more than we'd spent
building up to the time when the
expenses what about equally income but I
the point that I'm making is that the
income has exceeded our expectations and
whereas the outgo has not well there
will be some inflationary effect well
tear of this program that is to say it
will mean more expenditures than
otherwise yes mr. hazlit there'll be
some extent that it represents new
expenditures for people who would not
get the hospitalization otherwise it
would be inflationary to the extent it
merely takes the place of the money that
they would otherwise pay out of their
own pockets or whether it would not be
but on the other hand you've got to
balance that against the social games
here that come from now this
hospitalization i believe the present
estimate is that present expenditures
will be somewhere in the neighborhood of
70 million dollars this year since this
fiscal year and that we're going to run
into a deficit of somewhere in the
neighborhood of 7 billion dollars if I'm
remember the official estimates now in
view of that situation do you think this
is the proper time the most appropriate
time be pressing for increased
expenditures by the federal go out of a
fund that that's already in existence
this money is being collected now and it
it has no no relation to the general
overall tax program and budgetary
figures at all but it has a relation of
the money that can be spent and your
argument is that this look the golf set
by the Humane aspect of it yeah it
helped that is the water back to sir are
a great many Americans feel that while
we are spending so much money
prosecuting the Korean War and trying to
prevent a war with Russia a great many
Americans feel that we should cut down
on other expenditures by the government
now you think that at least at this the
extent of two hundred million dollars
that we should increase expenditures by
the federal gov these are not
expenditures by the federal government
these are but monies paid out of an
insurance fund that these people have
paid into but it is an expenditure of
our federal agency well this money spent
sure it's money spent money they if a
private insurance company spends money
it's money spent yes but they were going
to spend money you're you are now
putting out money enjoyment bond I'm not
taking it out of the taxpayers of the
country at all this money comes out of
funds that have been paid into the
Social Security Fund well now what are
you doing with the surplus money you are
now buying or bonds with it a government
bond that's true now you will have two
hundred million dollars a year less to
invest in government by well let me put
the problem this way mr. Ewing at
present you say we can afford to pay
this two hundred million dollars or
rather the government can because
otherwise the monies that come in are
not being spent but what assurance have
we that there won't be soon demands for
increasing the benefits under the
old-age insurance itself well you have
no insurance because you're perfectly
sure that they will be they'll always be
pressures to increase those benefits as
long as we live vani depends on the good
judgment of Congress to keep the
benefits
in line with the income and so far
Congress has done an admirable job you
don't regard yourself as a socialist new
you sir oh definitely not I haven't the
slightest sympathy with socialism well
then I'd like to ask one final question
mr. Ewing and to sum up you point is
that this program will cost only about
two hundred million dollars a year that
it isn't in any respect and entering
wedge for a larger program and it
doesn't bring you back that's to be
considered on its own merits and wholly
apart from your previous proposal of a
program that would cost from four to six
billion dollars that's right that's
about and even the be larger program mr.
Haslett would would be self-supporting
it there would be a special tax for that
yes well thank you very much for being
with us the editorial board for this
edition of the lawn gene Cronus cope was
mr. Henry Hazlitt and mr. william
bradford huie our distinguished guest
was mr. oscar are youing Federal
Security Administrator